Encased in a hard shell, brainless and possessing
only a single limb (a retractable foot that
looks like a tongue), clams seem like a species
for which reproduction would be difficult.
And yet, each year, millions of clams are
born – thanks in large part to chance.
During their life cycles, clams go through
several stages before they look and act like
a clam as we think of it.
When they reach this juvenile stage, all clams
are male – this works out because clam sperm
is much smaller and takes less resources to
produce than clam eggs.
The juvenile males simply couldn’t accommodate
eggs, nor have the metabolic resources required
to be able to produce them.
When they become adults and can devote more
energy to reproduction, rather than growing,
this ceases to be an issue.
In any event, clams begin making babies when
the water gets sufficiently warm, depending
on the location and the species, in the spring,
summer or fall.
For the Northern Quahog Clam (sometime called
the hard clam or Mercenaria mercenaria), this
happens in late spring/early summer when the
water reaches about 68F.
Called spawning, at the appointed time, the
smaller males release sperm into the ocean
to (hopefully) meet up with the eggs produced
by the larger (and older) clams that have
become females.
These millions of gametes join in the water
where fertilization occurs.
When a sperm and egg do manage to meet, the
cells of each young egg rapidly divide until
the embryo grows into a morula, a ball of
cells that resembles a mulberry (hence the
name).
After a day or two, cilia grow on the creature,
which again develops into a trocophore, a
free-swimming larva.
Continuing to change, the larva adds a shell
and a foot and becomes a veliger that spends
the next couple of weeks swimming around eating
plankton.
During the veliger stage, the body begins
to take on a clam-like shape, where one side
is straight (where the hinge will be), while
the other is rounded (where the clam will
ultimately open).
After this phase, the creature has the typical
bivalve appearance, with a hard shell and
well-developed foot (and is called a pediveliger).
Stiff and heavy, the juvenile sinks to the
ocean floor (in what is called the settling
stage).
The total time to reach this juvenile phase
is between 8 days and two weeks.
As a young clam, he uses his foot to dig in
the sand and move around (a bit), and a siphon
that extends from the shell to feed.
Many burrow under the sand with only the siphon
extending up into the water to filter-feed
on plankton.
When above the sand, clams’ photoreceptors
can distinguish when the shadow of a predator
floats above, an event which often sends them
diving for cover.
There they wait until it’s spawning time
again, and the life cycle repeats.
Only about 10% of fertilized eggs reach the
juvenile stage, but if the clam is savvy (or
just lucky) enough to avoid being eaten, it
can live for about 30 years, grow up to 4
inches across and become
a lady clam.